the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to talk all about
moments of inertia and the last time we
did muddy cards there were a lot of
questions the most common question you
know where all those terms come from and
I'm going to do a brief kind of intro
around that so as to get the rest of
this to facilitate the rest of it of the
discussions kind of some basic
assumptions here today we're going to
consider bodies that rotate about the
center of mass or fixed points that's
the kind of problems we're doing and
secondly all through this lecture today
there's four or five significant
assumptions or conditions that are
really important to the whole discussion
and I really try to highlight them I've
starting with two here the other one is
we're going to use reference frames
attached to the bodies that's why we did
all that work in kinematics figuring out
how to do velocities of things that are
in translating and rotating reference
range it's so that we can do these
problems okay
now fine so this said here's a inertial
frame here's some rigid body here's a
point on it that's my origin and here is
a set of coordinates attached to the
rigid body the XYZ system the body
rotates and it translates it goes with
it and if we consider a little piece of
this body a little mass part I'll call
it a little mass element am i from here
to here is some distance are i with
respect to a in the angular momentum of
that little mass particle is by just die
definition of angular momentum are I
cross P I the P I he is always the
linear momentum defined in an inertial
frame okay that's the definition of
angular momentum
so you've seen this this little demo
before but no so this is now my rigid
body that I'm talking about it I'm gonna
in this case it the axis of rotation is
this one and I'm just going to define my
rigid body it's essentially rotating
about this fixed point this is a now and
my coordinate system is X Y Z so the
rotation is Omega Z in this rigid body
this is massless it considers it can
consist of the single point mass okay
so we've done this before but we tended
to do this kind of problem using polar
coordinates and now I really wanted to
strictly think in terms of XYZ the
answers come out exactly the same polar
coordinates also moved you could do this
in our 1/2 theta hat z we're gonna do it
in X Y C X Y is the attached to the body
and why is going into the board we have
will have no values in the y-direction
for this problem here's our little mass
and call it m1 it's at a position out
here x1 z1 or it's coordinates and Y is
0
and we want to compute its angular
momentum h1 with respect to a that's our
r1 a cross P 1 and O and for this
problem
that's x1 in the I hat plus z1 in the K
hat that's the R cross P and P is mass
times you know its mass times velocity
m1 and the velocity is just Omega cross
R we've done this before so there's
gonna be a we need two lengths on this
thing we've done this enough times
before I'm assuming you can make this
leap with me if the momentum is into the
board it's in the y direction the linear
momentum is R cross with that and that
will give us let me write it yeah Omega
Z so that's the linear momentum it's in
the J direction it's velocity is x1
omega z it's the radius times the
rotation rate is the velocity the
direction is that direction so this is
your momentum you multiply out this
cross product you get two terms
m1 x1 squared Omega Z K minus m1 x1 z1
Omega Z I and these two terms then we
would identify this is the angular
momentum in the K direction the angular
momentum in the I direction that doesn't
happen to be any in the Z direction in
general there could be but this is H for
this particle article one we write it I
want to particularly emphasize this one
is this excuse me Z and this is the
piece we call H X so there's a component
of the angular momentum that's in the Z
direction there's a component in the X
direction so we know that if we compute
just to carry the the previous work a
lot tie it back to the previous work a
little further D by DT of H 1 a gives us
the torques the external torques in the
system a vector of torques when we
compute that out
I'm not going to calculate it we don't I
don't need it for the purposes of the
rest of discussion this one gives you a
magazine term this one gets two terms
because you have to take the derivative
of I so you get three terms which are
torque in the X torque and the white
organiz the directions two of them are
static because it's trying to bend this
thing back and out and one of them the z
direction one is the one that makes it
spin faster ok so you've seen that
that's a review and to make the leap
from that to rigid bodies
capital H now collection of particles
with respect to its the axis with the
origin attached to the rigid body is
going to be the summation over all the
little ass particles their position
vector crossed with the linear momentum
of all those little mass particles sum
all that out because it's a rigid body
this is always something of the form
that looks like Omega cross R and Omega
cross R and I can then write this as the
summation of rui of the mi RI a cross
Omega with respect to O cross RI a that
gives you the velocity times the moment
M gives you the linear momentum times
the cross with this one again makes it
into an angular momentum so everybody
everything the angular momentum of every
particle the term that the bits of this
come out looking like a like an R
squared Omega or at least has has
dimensions of R squared Omega these can
be like x1 squared but if these can also
be ends up being terms like x1 z1 those
cross product terms but in general and
the ease things all add up and this is
this is a vector this is a vector so
this is a vector Krotz these are all
vectors the results of vector right and
therefore we would break this down this
whole thing once you write all that out
and sum it all up you're going to get a
piece of it that we would say isn't that
is in the I hat direction
we call that HX another piece that's in
the J hat direction which we call hy an
HD in the K hat that's just how that all
shake out you're gonna get three and
generally you get three parts yeah why
do we have mass multiplied by a position
vector x and momentum because that is
the definition of angular momentum it's
R cross P right ah I see what I've done
yeah you're right this M doesn't belong
I got ahead of myself it doesn't belong
here
when it pops out of this to here thanks
for catching that absolutely right
so we're in the practice of these each
of these is every term here is made up
of things that look like x1 z1 m1 Omega
X Omega Y or Omega Z because this is a
vector and it can have three components
a piece in the eyepiece and the J a
piece in the K direction so when you
there's a lot of possible terms and
we're in the practice of writing this
out this H vector can be written then as
a I'm going to run out of room here
so the H X term the piece that comes out
with all little bits in the I direction
when you just break it apart we would
write it I xx Omega X plus I X Y Omega y
plus I XZ Omega Z these are all all the
AI terms that flowed out of this we just
write up we just collect them together
all the ones that are multiplied by
Omega X ends up being some terms that
look like sums of mi x mi with Z squared
terms and there's some Y squared terms
but we collect them all together and we
call this constant in front of it I xx
just what floats out of this stuff we
break it into three pieces the part of
the angular momentum due to the rotation
and the X the part due to the rotation
and the y the park due to the rotation
in the Z and you do the same thing for H
Y you get an I Y X Omega X plus I Y Y
Omega Y plus an I Y Z Omega Z and you
finally get an H Z term Z X Omega X Z Y
Omega Y Z Z Omega Z ok that's everything
that falls out of just rebuilding this
calculation
and we are in the habit of writing that
in a matrix notation as the product of
this thing called the inertia matrix and
so forth with this bottom term here same
evening the I ZZ x omega x omega omega z
you multiply that times the top row you
get HX middle row you get hy bottom row
you get the HC so where this stuff comes
from it's just from conducting carrying
out this summation over all mass bits so
it basically starts with the definition
of angular momentum and this is just a
convenient way to write it so for
example the I X Z term the one in the
upper right there that's part of HX the
I XZ term is minus the summation of all
the little mass bits times their
location x i's zi and this c XZ always
matches XZ and when you want to do this
over continuous object you integrate
that and 4i is easy this is the
summation of over i all the bits m I X I
squared plus y I squared okay so in
general this by as summations that's
where these terms come from they've just
come they started with this calculation
and in general from that calculation so
for our one particle system for this
thing so this is X and Z it's one single
particle so for our one particle system
and there's no y one in here because
it's zero in this problem right there's
no it's busy coordinate of that little
mass particle is X 1 0 y 1 so in general
this is X I squared plus y squared but
that's 0 so it's just M x1 squared
so that's where all these things come
from now let's kind of look at the units
of these things are always mass times
length squared the diagonal terms the x
ixx iyy eyes easy terms will all be of
the form of something squared and what
it is is it's always just the distance
of the mass particles from the axis of
rotation all that are it's just a
summation of this perpendicular distance
from the axis of rotation for i ZZ the
axis of rotation is z and this piece
here is always the distance squared that
the mass particle is from the axis of
rotation okay now that that's kind of
that's the set up for today and we want
to get on the real meated the discussion
are talking about things like the what
principal axes are and so forth
[Music]
so now we're going to move on to the
part of this conversation about
principal axes
so really important point for every
rigid body even weird ones for every
rigid body there is a coordinate system
that you can attach to this body at an
XYZ set of orthogonal coordinates that
you can fix in this body such that you
can make the this inertia matrix is
happy diagonal any weird body at all
there is a set of coordinates that oh if
you used that sent this this matrix
turns out to be diagonal and in terms of
what that means in dynamics terms is if
you then rotate the object about one of
those axes it will be dynamically
balanced and so when you rotate a shaft
this is a this is an object for which I
know it's a circular uniform disc one of
the axes through the center is a
principal axis and if I rotate the
object about that this one the holes
kind of out around so it wobbles a bit
but if I rotate it about that it will
have no it will make no torques about
this axis that are because it's
unbalanced okay
that's it's essentially the dynamic
meaning of principal axis of the axis
about which you can rotate the thing and
it'll just be smooth no no out of away
from the axis torques okay so that's so
those are pretty important we want to
know what those are for rigid bodies and
how to find them so there's a
mathematical way to find them and you
can do to read about it in the textbook
yeah the you know it's a sort of a I
think the mathematical term I forgot it
so the but what I want to teach you
today is for many many objects if you
just look at their symmetries you can
figure out my common sense or where
their principal axes are so that's what
we're going to do next
we started off saying that we're talking
about bodies that are either rotating
about their centers of mass or about
some other fixed point okay so we're now
we're going to talk about we're going to
define our principal axes assuming we
are rotating about the center of mass
there's an easy theme Adnan as the
parallel axis theorem to get to any
other point so why do we want it why do
we care about doing it about the center
of mass why is that useful to know about
the properties around the center for
dynamics purposes what kind of dynamics
problems do you care about the center of
mass rotation about the center area
okay so when I throw this thing in the
air its rotating it's translating and
when it rotates what's it rotating about
mass so there's just lots and lots of
problems in which in fact the rotation
is going to occur around the center of
mass anytime the thing is off there and
there's no nothing constraining its
rotational motion the rotational will be
about the center of mass so that's a
good that's a good enough reason the
practice are very practical then reason
for computing these things or knowing
how to find these things about the
center of mass all right so we're now
we're going to do so we're doing
principal axes and I'm gonna teach you
some symmetry rules maybe first a little
common sense this thing does this a
principal axis no way right and we know
for a fact that it doesn't have has off
diagonal terms because I've defined my
coordinates as being an XYZ like this
and this is off at some strange angle so
it's a practical matter how can I make
this the how could I make this object
alter this object so that this is a
principal axis this is essentially how
would you balance this or alright we're
put it here
now you want to like this alright steel
going into aluminum I have to be careful
that I don't strip the threads there we
go
and now test test one this is the axis
rotation it's a dynamically unbalanced
smooth as silk
okay this now is a principal axis this
thing has its mass distribution is
symmetric and the plane of symmetry
there's a plane where is there a plane
of symmetry for this problem for this
object that's we're gonna talk about now
planes of symmetry axes of symmetry oh
yeah you see any more like bad you're
right that's a plane of symmetry is
there another one for this one like this
this two planes of symmetry okay so
let's let's let's come up with some
rules for some symmetry rules so this
first one is there exists
by this I mean diagonal it's a diagonal
matrix you can find a set of our thuggin
axes such that this matrix is diagonal
that's what we mean when we go to find
principal axes okay
I'm gonna pick a board here rules
and we're gonna have three of them so
just leave room on your paper we're
going to build these up and I'm going to
talk about it and then you add another
one and so forth
okay so rule one yeah what is the
inertia matrix this thing with the
diagonals this is going to have all the
off-diagonal terms are zeroes that's
what I mean
it's a diagonal matrix there's the mass
moments of inertia and products of
inertia you only have ixx iyy is easy if
you properly pick this set of our thoug
g''l coordinates attached to the body if
you pick them right what it means if you
then you spend that object about one of
those axes it's it's it's in balance
okay so rule one so if there is an axis
of symmetry
okay remember the caveat here is we're
talking about uniform density objects or
at least objects in which the density is
symmetrically distributed alright so the
geometric symmetry and mass symmetry
mean the same thing okay
what's what does that mean so axis of
symmetry does this have an axis of
symmetry where that's a plane of
symmetry the other ones you think so
axis of symmetry which way no okay axis
of symmetry means that you can you know
and they're a mirror image from that
point that point mirror image over here
is always identical but you can pick it
any from any angle doesn't matter where
you start it's reflected through the
axis so things that are circularly
shaped tend to have axes of symmetry so
this has an axis of symmetry any
everything reflected exactly just across
the axis you don't have to pick any
particular line so for an axis of
symmetry what it's saying if it's an
axis of symmetry then it is a principal
axis and rotation about that axis the
thing will be nice perfectly in balance
you go through all the hairy details of
calculating the hard way the ixx iyy
etcetera terms all of the off diagonal
terms will come out zero and the reason
is that for every mass particle over
here let's say there's a little bit
right here in the corner there is one
exactly like it on the other side so if
this one we're trying to make bend this
thing up as it spins around
this one over here is telling to come
back yeah I think it's kind of just
definition we're getting to an axis of
symmetry because the object and kind of
simple terms the the what the object
looks like this way it's it's a narrow
object it is in fact a ramírez
reflection but it looks different when
you go to this angle it looks different
when you go to this angle so it's not an
axis of symmetry that's a plane of
symmetry and we're going to talk about
that next
so axes of symmetry the thing
essentially looks the same at all
orientations about that axis okay so but
it is certainly it's dynamically
balanced it it doesn't have every mass
fit here it balances one over there it
doesn't wobble all right so that's a
fruit that's for sure true now keep in
fact keep in mind that there exists an
orthogonal a set of orthogonal axes so
that means once you find one you know
that the other two are perpendicular to
it and perpendicularly to each other so
for this system what I've got x and y
here there has to be an x and y
perpendicular that that are the other
two and for because it's actually
symmetric then where you put them you
could just say it's these two these two
these two doesn't matter you just have
to decide where you're gonna put them on
the object they're all the same okay so
for this axis of symmetry they're just
two more they're going to be in the body
perpendicular to the first now we're
going to do it about G so the book uses
G to talk about it as the center of mass
I'll use G so the center of mass of this
thing is right in the middle of this and
in the middle here so it's inside this
body right in the dead center of it
right okay so the principal axes are an
orthogonal set one of which goes through
it and the other two are embedded in it
so if you have this is the simplest rule
if you have an axis of symmetry you know
right away just about everything you
need to know about the principal axis of
the body okay shoot yeah but they sure
appear an awful lot in machines because
they have this beautiful property of
just being balanced in all directions
okay so everything rotating in the world
tends to have almost perfect axial
symmetry okay
just thinking about order here let's do
let's do this and then I'm going to go
do a couple of examples the second rule
if you have one one plane of symmetry
okay what a plane of symmetry so this
kind of the simp the opposite direction
this you have the least information
here's an object does it have a plane of
symmetry
where
back alright so I got these little
dotted marks on this day so if I if I
slice through that I create two pieces
that are identical so that's a plane of
symmetry there's image match across that
plane at every point okay so if I have a
plane of symmetry what do you think you
can say about a principal axes one of
the principal axes you'll be on that
plane that turns out to be true but
that's the second point I want to make
she says it might be it might be one
perpendicular to it and that's the one I
was searching for you're right - okay
there's going to be an axis a principal
axis that's perpendicular to that plane
of symmetry and since we wanted to find
our moments of inertia for this to get
start with with respect to G where will
it pass through G get kind of by
definition so we're gonna have it passed
through G if there's a plane of symmetry
then
there is a principal axis perpendicular
to it and we'll define it for the
purposes of our discussion we'll we'll
just let it pass through G so doesn't
have to but that's how we're going about
this discussion let it pass through the
center of mass this point we call G all
right all right so that means that
there's a point there's a sinner there's
a center of mass in this thing and I'm
just guessing roughly where it is but in
fact you know if I hung this thing up
here like this and if it let gravity
find its find its natural hanging angle
and I drew a plumb line down here and
just drew a line that's the string would
take with a plumb bob then I went to
some other point did it again and hung a
plumb bob on it and drew the line where
the intersect is gener mass okay and
then you know since it's got symmetry
this way that it's in the middle so I
guessed that that's about where it is
and there then is a principal axis of
this object that passes that's
perpendicular to it back passing through
the plane perpendicular to the plane and
that means now there's two more that
this gets a little more difficult and I
don't I have no clue there are two more
because the principal axes are always
coming in orthogonal set so now that I
know one I know that there's two more
somewhere around mounted you know
oriented with this or someplace in this
plane you know maybe one like that maybe
one like this such that if you spun it
about one of those axes that'd be in
balance and you can see that gets a
little messy I can't guess where it is
and so there are ways to find it what it
would be doing an experiment seeing
which axis is spins nicely around so
that's second
but even just with that one plane of
symmetry that's you you'd get some
pretty good insight okay now what if
there are two planes of symmetry yeah
no we're yeah I'm saying it doesn't have
to pass through the center of masses the
question is keep saying it the unstable
it's not like I put an axle through this
will you I spun it about some point out
here we you know because I had that
shaker in here that thing is gonna shake
like crazy right but it does it produce
unbalanced torques about my rotation
point it'll produce a centrifugal force
that you'll feel like crazy but does it
produce at or trying to that you'd have
to resist with some static door what do
you think whoa so there's a nuance to
this unbalanced thing and I was going to
get to it probably next lecture but and
that is that when we say an object is
dynamically balanced we mean that it
doesn't have any unbalanced torques if
we if it is statically balanced it
doesn't it's rotating about its center
of mass but you can be statically
unbalanced and let it go around this
axis but it'll produce no torques it's
still dynamically balanced and the
angular momentum of an object which is
rotating in distant we know has a
principal axis here I've just moved it
off to the side it's rotating about this
it is dynamically balanced and if you
computed the off die about this point
now the I X Y I actually off diagonal
entries in that moment of inertia matrix
or l0 you'd get note or note unbalanced
torques but you do have an unbalanced
centrifugal force as this thing goes
around
[Music]
right so she's asking about the
motorcycle wheel problem or we had that
little mass that got there I think in
the next lecture I'm going to bring I'm
going to come back to that problem just
so that we could tie a bow around this
whole thing and understand how how you
why it's unbalanced how you can balance
it in a difference between static
unbalance and dynamic imbalance but
today we're talking about symmetry rules
okay finally so I was saying let's talk
about something that has two planes of
symmetry this actually has three planes
of symmetry but we'll settle for two
plaintiffs networkers a whereas pick
pick a plane of symmetry for this object
and if I pick a and a third right
there's even one like that so this is
three points of symmetry but if you have
two planes of symmetry that intersect
that are orthogonal to one another what
do you think you can say about that line
of intersection it in it and it sure is
and it's probably right through G okay
so if you have two planes of symmetry
now making more thuggin oh you can make
all sorts of symmetry rules and I'm just
picking these three to make it to help
you out this just to help you see
principal axes if you have two
orthogonal planes of symmetry they're
intersection and once you know that then
you go back to Rule two and it tells you
everything else you need to know because
you have one plane of symmetry you know
that there is an act for a principle
axis perpendicular to it well if you
have two planes of symmetry rules still
hold there's one perpendicular to each
one the intersection let's say of this
plane of symmetry and this plane of
symmetry is a line which goes right
through dead through the center of this
thing that way so there's a principle
axis this way but since there is a plane
of symmetry here there must also be a
principle axis perpendicular to it so
sure enough the three principal axes for
this thing are through the center
perpendicular this way perpendicular
that way instantly no two planes of
symmetry you instantly know where the
three orthogonal principal axes are that
pass through the center of mass okay
yeah
not constant symmetrically symmetrically
distributed density all right so I want
what I'm trying to accuse me my words
carefully so that I succeed in the
following that the planes defining mass
symmetry will be the same as the planes
defining geometric similarity but you
actually don't have to have constant
density it just has to be distributed so
that what I just said is true so that
the geometric symmetries are the same as
the mass distribution symmetries all
right so those are my three rules of
symmetry you could make up others those
are the three that I've made up to help
you see objects okay bad object it's a
circular disk put on top of of another
object such they're CG there's of mass
lineup where are the principal axes of
this object using those rules
you think you know one tell me
alright get through the middle of OPA
all right probably good guess how about
another one in where are their planes
where does this thing at planes of
symmetry right okay and one like that we
just stick we've got all three but and
if we're going to want it to go through
the center mass and we're gonna find
where the center of mass is this way but
it's you know about there let's say okay
so just using these symmetry ideas you
can right away figure out where these
principal axes be and that means I'm
dead from a dynamic point of view if you
spin it about one of those actually its
axes it's nice and dynamically balanced
if you spin it off in some other weird
direction is it necessarily dynamically
balanced about that axis of spin
so let me restate that question we know
that this thing has an axis of symmetry
at principal axis through the center as
another one this way and another one
this way and if I spin it about any one
of those its dynamically balanced but if
I pick some other strange direction for
the spin and I spin it about that axis
will I feel unbalanced torques on this
axle on the bearings having to hold this
thing in place yeah you better believe
the principal axes are a property of the
object they're not a property of the
angular momentum the angular momentum
comes then from multiplying the mass
moment of inertia that you've determined
times the actual rotation vector and
you'll find out that you get angular
components of angular momentum that
not in the direction of spin as soon as
that happens you have unbalanced germs
okay I got to get on to something else
before it to help you do homework that's
[Applause]
[Applause]
so for my disk with Z coming out of
board the eyes easy so let's say here's
X Y Z coming out of the board eyes easy
the mass district mass moment of inertia
about this the axis is from the basic
definition the summation of the M is X I
squared plus y squared it's just that
for every little mass particle it's the
dist it's the radius squared away from
the center of rotation
that's what x squared plus y squared is
and we can turn this into an integral
it's the integral of R squared that
distance times the little mass bit
that's there and if that's the same if
you wanted to do the integral as x
squared plus y squared DM okay but to do
this integral for a nice circularly
symmetric disk well you can pick a
little mass bit that has thickness D R
and width Rd theta and this angle here
is d theta and that's a little bit of
area that's a little d a which has area
r dr d-theta
it's just length times width it's a
little but it's when it's small enough
it's a little rectangle and it has that
area and it has a volume DV the volume
of that thing is just the area times the
thickness of it so here's our disk here
but it has some thickness and I'll call
that H so the volume is just H R
or D theta and the mass DM is a density
times DV so I want to integrate this all
I have to integrate the integral then of
R squared DM is the integral from 0 to
2pi 0 to R of Rho DV Rho H oh and I need
an R squared R squared DV is Rho H R dr
d-theta
so this is 1802 integrals right so this
is then is this if any of this a
function of theta nope so it's a trivial
integral just gives you integrate that
over theta you just get theta evaluated
zero to 2pi so this is 2 pi Rho H can
all come to the outside integral 0 to r
of r cubed dr and that and keep the r
cubed go to R to the fourth over 4 and
the final result of this one is 2 pi R
to the fourth over 4 Rho H and when you
account for H times PI R squared is
volume times Rho is the mass this all
works out to be M R squared over 2 ok so
I ZZ so I need to do this once for you
for simple things to integrate as easy
in this case you just integrate it out
account for all the little mass bits
that is the mass moment of inertia with
respect to the axis passing through the
center like this
pardon it's this this is what I'm
talking about okay so we need is moving
on to the last bit so we need to know
how to be able to rotate things about
parts places other than their centers of
mass so this is a stick I can rotate it
about the center of mass but it's more
interesting if I rotate it about some
other point makes it a pendulum when I
do it around here so I need to be able
to calculate mass moments of inertia
about a point that's not through the
center of mass now I know you've seen
this before in in 801 so this is going
to be a quick reminder that I'll show
you where it comes from
so here's my stick
and I'm going to have the center of mass
and that's where G is located here it
has a length total length L I'm gonna
give it a thickness B a width a okay so
just it's a stick a wide be thick metal
long uniform has a center of gravity
right in the middle and I'm going to
attach to this stick a and this this
point it's kind of hard to draw this
points is that the in the center of the
stick okay I'm going to put my
coordinate system attached at the center
of gravity center of mass and I'm gonna
make it the that's X prime downward z
prime and y prime is then going off that
way so this is a body set of coordinates
at the center of mass X prime Y prime Z
Prime and X happens to be down and I
want to move I want to calculate my mass
moment of inertia with respect to a
point up here that is d its distance
I've moved up the x-axis and amount D so
I'm gonna set a new coordinate system up
here so if this was Z prime my new Z is
here is getting a little messy
and maybe out just a face view if my
previously Y Prime and X prime for like
that Z coming out of the board now I
have a new system that is y and X like
this Z still come in out of the board
all right
now the coordinate so how do I calculate
mass moment of inertia well I want to I
want to know I want eyes easy I probably
know I Z prime Z prime Z prime Z prime
is the mass moment of inertia about this
point I know it's a principal axis from
all the row things we just square block
is the same as this that's the principal
axis in the Z prime direction I know the
eysie Z Prime with respect to G I want
to know it with respect to this point so
well i ZZ which is my new location up
here and we'll call it a so i ZZ here
with respect to a is the integral of R
squared DM got to do the same integral
now and but that's the integral of x
squared plus y squared DM but now I can
look at this and I say oh well these are
D this is separated by D I only moved it
in the X the Y's haven't moved and the
Z's didn't change I've just moved my
point only in the X Direction so I can
now say that hmm
in terms of my new coordinate it's the
same as X prime plus D the distance from
here to a point down here some mass
point some arbitrary mass point X I is
going to be X I prime plus D ok so to do
this integral in the new coordinates
this is going to be the integral of X
prime plus d squared plus y now why
prime equals y and z prime equals Z
those haven't changed I didn't move mine
coordinate system in the Y direction or
the Z direction so the coordinate in the
new system in Y is the same as before so
this is just Y prime squared and this
whole thing times integrated x every
little mass bit I'm gonna if I expand if
I Square this I get X prime squared - X
prime D d squared plus y squared so this
integral I is easy with respect to a and
you rearranged it looks like X prime
squared plus y prime squared DM and the
some integral of a sum to sum of the
integrals so I break it into bits here
there's a d squared which is a constant
DM and then the last term is plus 2 D
and it's X Prime DM that's what this
just multiply this out rewrite it break
it apart integral of well let's do this
one integral of X prime squared plus y
prime for a DM you know that's something
that we already have a name for this is
I G in Z Z it's the original mass moment
of inertia with respect to the original
coordinate system at G in the Z
direction so it's I ZZ g ok that's it we
already know that that's given for the
object Plus this is the integral of DM
over the whole extent of the object just
to mass the object
this integral this is the integral in
terms of the x-coordinate and every mass
bit from here if I go out here and find
one there's an equal and opposite one up
here this is the definition of the
center of mass this integral if I'm at
the center of mass integrating out from
it this is zero because of the
definition of the center of mass and
I've just proven the parallel axis
theorem is easy about this new point is
I about G plus MD squared where D
squared is the distance I've moved the z
axis to a new place parallel to it okay
so I Zizi with fur with respect to G the
original mass moment of inertia for
wrote in the four eyes easy is M l
squared plus a squared over 12 and I XX
m l squared plus b squared over 12 and i
ZZ well we are we already know that one
oh wait a minute
I don't haven't told you what that is
that's i ZZ ixx iyy this little messy
here i YY for this problem is
I have made a mistake I X X is a squared
plus B squared I YY is M L squared plus
B squared so those are the three all
with respect to G for this stick okay
and I'm going to that kind of sets us up
where I can pick up next time so let's
finish by asking ourselves the question
what do we think about if I've moved to
this new put new position not rotating
about the center is this new axis this
one around the center before that one we
know is a principal axis is the new if I
rotate about this new place which I've
defined the mass moment inertia about
that place is this a principal axis how
many think yes how many think no okay so
little and lots of people not sure so
the dynamic my dynamic definition of
principal axis is if you can rotate the
object about that axis and produce no
unbalanced torques
it's a principal axis and I can do that
this thing will just spin all day long
now there is a force there's you can
think of it the most fictitious force
there's a center of mass out here as it
spins around there's a centripetal
acceleration making it go in the circle
that means that fictitious force is like
there is a centrifugal force pulling out
on it do I feel that do I have to resist
that force as it goes round and round
yes so there that is an unbalanced of a
kind
we know as a static imbalance but it
doesn't produce torques about this that
my G my center of my axis right lined up
on this Center okay sure but that's not
a different problem that's what makes
this thing act like an oscillator okay
the torques of the kind I'm talking
about is if I compute the angular
momentum of this thing and take compute
dhdt the time rate of change of the
angular momentum is a torque on the
system right I will get the term that
makes it spin faster and I will get if
they exist terms that make it want to
bend this way or bend you know Bend back
and it only happens if if I if I if I
hold this thing over here
and spin it get it spinning and I
compute the angular momentum with
respect to this point
well I get torques yeah but that's not
how I that's that's that's a different
problem we computed I the IG is as if I
were computing the angular momentum ice
member I started defining mass moment of
inertia matrix based on an angular
momentum computation at G so it's right
there in the center of this object
there's no moment arm that is causing
torques that's trying to twist this
thing about that point okay so and the
answered question is this is a this is a
principal axis yeah
and either torques that aren't in that
direction
you either you made a mistake doing the
math or you started you were in error in
identifying the mass moment of inertia
matrix to begin with because if you get
torques there must be non-zero
off-diagonal terms in the mass moment of
inertia matrix they are what account for
the torques okay so any by this parallel
axis theorem any other axis you go to if
you started at a principal axis any
other axis you create is also a
principal axis that's the movement of
just one axis if you do two if you move
this way and this way is all bets are
off you get a different answer and if
you're interested in that more
complicated problem read that Williams
thing because he does the complete
parallel axis parallel planes and comes
with a super compact little way of
calculating them okay see you on
Thursday
you